and just in time for tax season thieves
targeting mailboxes to try and steal
your information a North Las Vegas man
says his neighborhood near Craig and
Clayton has been hit four times as Brian
will Reports most recently thieves using
his information to access his debit and
credit cards imagine walking out to your
mailbox to find this thieves have broken
in this has happened more than just once
here in this neighborhood in North Las
Vegas they're so sophisticated they're
drilling out the lock from the back pop
the door opens and take all your
information that's exactly what happened
to Pedro Hernandez and his neighbor's
mailboxes not once but four times since
October of last year they broke into the
the main box they stole some of my
identification they got into my debit
card they got into my credit card the
bank had to shut everything down this
wasn't the only headache it caused
Hernandez and his neighbors the mailman
will not drop any mail off if the box is
broken into
so therefore we have to drive to the
post office and he is still driving to
the post office every day waiting for
the problem to be addressed I think the
post office should react to some of
these problems immediately because it's
our mail it's our privacy it's a federal
offense the post office tells me mail
theft is a top priority for United
States Postal inspection service they
also say they are aware of mail theft
reports in that area and are actively
working to stop it they won't say what
steps they are taking to prevent or stop
these thefts we need to do something
about it
Hernandez tells Brian that neighbors
reported seeing two men in a black truck
breaking into the mailboxes if you have
any information please contact North Las
Vegas police and report it to the postal
inspection service